foreign
[Music]
take in all that is around you
let's go again
I have reason to believe the Empire is
still a threat we Face Another War let's
begin
Ahsoka Taylor Anakin spoke highly of you
get ready
got any more
Ahsoka two episode premiere streaming
August 23rd
always do there are no more no less
a master
Apprentice
be mindful of the living false young
Padawan
[Music]
will be tempted by the dark side of the
force
a Must Destroy in order to create
faster it's been a while things have
changed
sometimes we have to do what's right
[Music]
that is the true burden of all Masters
also got two episode premiere streaming
August 23rd on Disney Plus
[Music]
thank you